i have to say um the i know you're
laughing at this movie the reference but
twister i love so much and i'm from
texas
oh so oklahomans in texas really
identify with that film yeah
um but i i is it true that like when
y'all shot that it was sunny the whole
time
it is true the port director i mean how
did he do that
so he blasted a lot of light in our
faces
oh and then took the film film
that was been a while and turned it all
gray but it was i think if you
prepare for that giant movie get there
and the sun is shining you're pretty
bummed out
yeah i mean that's not motivating no
like yeah yeah like for your for your
role but they made up for that
by beating the crap out of us i mean it
was before
um computer animation was so great yeah
so there was just guys there was a giant
fan and guys with just piles of stuff
that they would put in front of the fan
that would then fly on to us
but you almost didn't take the role at
first right in what movie
and twister oh yeah i don't know it
seemed like
probably the tornado's the star of this
movie and what's the part good is the
part going to be and then i
got taken to a fancy lunch where steven
spielberg said please do it and i said
okay
oh my god because when he asked you do
it yeah and i and they picked great
actors there's wonderful actors in
it you know so that director's smart
that way he knows to make a big movie
with good actors
it is such a classic everybody i know
loves that movie ann catway i love that
you're like and anybody like cassaway
i'm like like the human race
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever